llegó el momento de repasar la
información económica en france 24 para
ello contamos de nuevo con nuestro
periodista especializado jorge hurtado
bienvenido jorge cuéntanos por qué
aparecen más predicciones del impacto
económico que tiene la guerra en ucrania
así es y ahora es el turno para la
organización la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico ocde que presentó
un simulador del impacto esperado por
este conflicto según ellos la guerra le
costará al mundo un punto porcentual en
el crecimiento económico y hasta dos
puntos a la unión europea asimismo
afectará la inflación de por sí elevada
por las medidas de la pandemia del cob y
19 vamos a ver los detalles en el
siguiente informe de juan pabló lucumí
la guerra en ucrania le pasará factura a
la economía internacional según la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico este año el
producto interno bruto mundial podría
ser un punto conceptual más bajo y aún
peor debido a la guerra la inflación
podría aumentar hasta dos puntos
porcentuales
lewis la guerra está provocando un
fuerte choque de oferta que se suma a
las presiones inflacionarias ya las
perturbaciones por la crisis del cob y
19 está el impacto negativo sobre la
confianza que al mismo tiempo afectará
negativamente en el consumo privado y en
las decisiones de inversión de las
empresas
aunque rusia y ucrania solo representan
el 2% del producto interno bruto mundial
su impacto en los mercados de la energía
y las materias primas es enorme rusia
suministra el 27 por ciento de las
importaciones de crudo de la unión
europea y más del 41 por ciento del gas
natural al bloque aunque exporta más
productos a américa latina' de los que
importa la mayor parte de las
exportaciones rusas llegan a brasil y
méxico las dos mayores economías de la
región representadas en fertilizantes
acero petróleo refinado y las vacunas
sputnik
en el contexto actual europa en
particular tendrá que estar a la altura
de las circunstancias y reevaluar la
estructura y el diseño del mercado para
garantizar la seguridad y el acceso a la
energía sin dejar de centrarse en lograr
la neutralidad del carbono para 2050 el
organismo internacional mencionó que
eeuu y la zona euro serían los más
afectados y recomiendo a los gobiernos
que las medidas que se tomen en los
períodos de crisis deben ser temporales
y específicas de lo contrario podrían
tener efectos aún peores
y es que según este informe el efecto de
la guerra se va a sentir en todas las
partes del mundo esto principalmente por
el golpe a la demanda global y el poder
adquisitivo debido a la inflación que
aumentaría los precios en 2,5 puntos
porcentuales más de lo que se esperaba
el informe también detalla una
proyección del precio de las principales
materias primas y advierte del
incremento de hambruna y escasez de
alimentos en países de medio oriente y
áfrica del norte el organismo afirma que
las sanciones occidentales harán que la
producción de rusia se hunda un 10 por
ciento porque sentiremos todos
probablemente las consecuencias de la
guerra vamos ahora hasta inglaterra
porque el barco central de inglaterra
precisamente subió los tipos de interés
así es y lo hace siguiendo una tendencia
del resto de bancos centrales del mundo
para contener precisamente los efectos
de la inflación reino unido subió los
tipos del 0,5 por ciento al 0.75 por
ciento esta se convierte en la tercera
subida en cuatro meses para
contrarrestar el alza en el costo de la
vida y en la inflación interanual se
ubica en 55 % muy por encima del
objetivo del 2 por ciento que se había
fijado el banco con este incremento los
tipos de interés se sitúan ahora en su
máximo nivel desde marzo de 2020 cuando
estalló precisamente la pandemia de
coronavirus ayer la reserva federal de
eeuu subió su tipo de interés en un
cuarto de punto los tipos de interés son
las fórmulas que se encargan de medir el
precio del dinero las subidas de los
tipos de interés buscan controlar la
inflación y frenar de alguna forma el
aumento de los precios y nos vamos hasta
otro país cercano hasta alemania que se
cuenta que pronósticos hay para la
economía alemana con esta guerra en
ucrania así es y es que según el
instituto para la economía mundial de
kiel pronosticó que esa economía crecerá
este año un 2,1 por ciento la mitad de
lo que se había calculado en su última
previsión
según el organismo el costo total de la
guerra para alemania será de 90 mil
millones de euros en términos de
producción a lo largo de este año y del
que viene esto por el aumento de los
precios de las materias primas y los
cuellos de botella en la cadena de
suministros en la eurozona la tasa de
inflación
a sus niveles más elevados desde el
establecimiento de la unión monetaria
con un 52 por ciento este instituto se
encuentra entre los cinco principales
institutos de estudios económicos de
alemania y se encargan de elaborar un
informe semestral para el gobierno
alemán sobre el estado y las
predicciones de la economía y en francia
continúan las protestas por el alza del
precio de los combustibles así rodrigo
este bloqueo se da empresa al oeste de
francia que comenzó el martes por la
mañana y mantiene bloqueado un depósito
de petróleo por camiones y tractores los
manifestantes son profesionales de la
obra pública de la construcción así como
conductores y pescadores que protestan
por los altos precios de los
combustibles que ponen en riesgo su
negocio el precio de barril de petróleo
brent para entrega en mayo terminó en
106 dólares un 8,91 por ciento más que
al finalizar la sesión anterior esto en
el mercado de futuros de londres la
guerra en ucrania mantiene la
volatilidad de los precios mientras los
países exportadores de petróleo todavía
no han dicho o no han mostrado su
capacidad para aumentar la producción y
por último jorge cuéntanos que muestran
los indicadores de las bolsas
internacionales
empezamos en eeuu y las acciones de wall
street se recuperaron de las pérdidas
del inicio de sesión ya que los
inversores sopesaron las implicaciones
económicas de la política monetaria de
la reserva federal sobre los tipos de
interés en europa las acciones cerraron
en positivo por el optimismo de la
reserva federal sobre la fortaleza
económica de eeuu en américa latina la
bolsa mexicana de valores registró una
ganancia del 1 78 por ciento en su
principal indicador imponiendo un nuevo
máximo histórico no sé muchas gracias
por otro excelente reparto económico a
los espectadores les invitamos a que
sigan con nosotros
[Música]